hello good honest trailer commentaries I
am Spencer de Gilbert and pay no
attention to candy wrappers cuz I am
also an adult I'm here as always with
Joestar look and Dan Morelle
here's the thing about snow kits I'm
sorry I went into autopilot mode
I'm so sorry about totally different
because we are talking about the honest
trailer to Jumanji which you should
watch and then come back to this video
if you haven't seen it yet we're gonna
be talking along as we watch the honest
trailer and if you stick around till
afterwards got some deleted scenes some
cut jokes some treats get to see the
things that weren't funny enough to make
it in what a dream guys those it like to
revisit Jumanji 20 years later I had
never seen you mine oh I don't know how
I missed it but I did and as a grown man
I was like if I had kids that were old
enough to see this movie I would
promptly decided they were not old
enough to see this movie like 10 minutes
it's it's pretty intense
yeah very glad that we touched on that
in this trailer because I do I was about
12 I guess when this movie came out and
it is very even for a 12 year old which
that's an older kid it's it just feels
very strangely serious yeah disturbing
kids are screwed up I'm gonna casually
take off my headphones and pretend like
I'm not the only one that's been wearing
them the whole video you made here no no
nobody noticed okay just be cool
completely flawless yeah like she's got
a weird like lying thing and then like
the little boys super manipulative
because they're orphans
oh yeah they've gone they've gone
through some some stuff their parents
just died and they meet up with other
orphans were orphaned because they spent
20 years in a jungle board game and it's
warped their minds and yeah this movie
plays it very real real very like
psychologically real of like how
traumatic it would be to play this board
game that keeps trying to kill you and
you can't escape from yeah also many as
a choice very bold choice also one of
the many relics of that wonderful like
95 to 2000 era of early
computer-generated effects where there
was a lot of confidence
there yes a lot of how much executes
well as good as at an execution as was
possible at that but we didn't know any
better I remember seeing it she's like
oh my god this damn the Stampede is
amazing I got that monkeys the monkeys
didn't look so yeah those monkeys going
the mortal kombat reptile pile I think
yeah I was blown away when I first saw
Mortal Kombat I mean the effects wise
like I didn't know reptile looked stupid
that's true yeah I'm sure we'll look
back on today and be like wow what
garbage they didn't even Jack right into
your brainstem and you know make you
smell what was happening Jerry how dare
they I'm tanning I wanted to smell that
salt yeah the guy tasting it and saying
salt picks it up and he goes salt Wow so
in five years you're gonna have you're
right you can have a little brain thing
that goes in your head and when the guy
again does especially gonna taste the
salt oh if I could taste the milk
Luke drinks smelled the vine darts and
yeah and the crocodile waters yeah and
the smoke from the hunters gun and I
guess the other big thing about this
film is is Robin Williams it's always
great to see him and and revisit Robin
Hood's movies but like know it played to
his strengths at the start when he's
like this wild man and stuff like yeah
but they he's not a funny role because
he's just so tortured like they did they
did what they did what I don't like
about hook is that they like repress him
for so much of the film yeah I mean but
I do believe that he's the reason why
the new zoom on G is a reboot instead of
a remake that movie would have been a
remake I think if Robin Williams I did I
did see the new one and it's it's a read
yeah yeah I mean they have to call it a
reboot because I think a there's a
little of the original and then you
don't want to ever be in a position
where you're kind of wiping out Robin
Williams and any of his beloved movies
but it's essentially a remake but I
think the reason they call it a
because he is a beloved figure who you
know I and this is kind of the reason it
wasn't as bad is like when I watch folks
sometimes I'm like it's kind of a downer
this movie I think it's just you expect
crazy man and he's not but actually
don't mind him so much it's just it's
not what you expect because he can do he
can do sad and down her like world to
grin his dad like he couldn't yeah do
that stuff but I I agree I think we
jumps out of the game wearing leaves and
like going this is the the Robin wounds
we're gonna get and then pretty soon
it's like mom and dad okay alright well
with that why don't we dive into the
dark depths of Jumanji the other skater
let's head to the much
[Music]
you've seen good board game movies like
clue
I love cliff and collector inherence
that's about it now get ready for a
movie with more scares than we G more
quality than Dungeons & Dragons and
about a thousand times more logic than
battleship Mahalo
let's train to Fanny for battleship just
because the wall is at paws just like
the oh good place to possibly give me
the rocketry there is 25 points but just
like the pitch meeting for battleship or
like the different takes they've got on
that story or it's like should we make
like a Navy movie where like people
shoot each other should we make a kids
movie where it's like the game like a
cartoon no aliens come down and then
create a bubble dome yes for which to
duel the Navy and then they knock out
their radar systems so that they have to
use a grid like it was the most
convoluted mousetrap way to get into
making together if you go like b4 grid
yeah battleships got to be in the lower
tier of classic board games for me it's
it's it's above monopoly but not by much
I yeah I mean I think older you get you
to figure out where we're gonna kid on
our block who you use the rich kid and
you news the rich kid because he had
electronic battleship and we plebs just
had pegs planet eggs yeah I had to make
the awful electronic noises by myself do
you ever have battleship tiers no no
people people : cheaters you tell them
that they missed and you know to extend
the game it is very sons of [ __ ]
battle shots much better game yeah it's
it's supposed to game with shot glasses
instead of cement Wow g4 and then you
drink scotch yep I like that yeah yeah
yeah alright moving on paper I went to
Florida State
party catched up 16 the rocks 25 Joe you
wrote this is this plan and let's back
up to the plan I guess any any insights
you can give us I feel like it's mostly
the plot to the Transformers animated I
mean there's a little more subtlety than
that Spencer yeah Spencer said hey write
this 25 point plan and I think I had
already written it in my head years back
and so I spent 30 seconds and sent it to
him it's a little rocks actual life it's
a little loved ancient aliens and a
whole lot of Transformers references and
I hope you enjoyed that is Joe star also
yes show a little bit of rocks actual
life this list is just mean clothes yeah
yeah so there you go I think it's a
pretty solid list he really is going to
go to step 18 the president one I don't
know about replacing Kyle Gass that's
kind of that's too far I do like reveal
selfs as actual score yes absolutely
happen but you know the pyramid ships I
don't know Unicron god of chaos I don't
know because you know I don't I I'm
agnostic I don't have all the religion
answers so I don't know if he's real or
not the guy stay open to that disability
exact but actual scorpion king
absolutely
okay then Unicron that person will
children's classic that's way to
children talk to the fence at scariest
of all doesn't give Robin Williams
anything funny to say we have New Year
the Clampetts have a yard sale of his
childhood wonderful mrs. niedelmeyer
still teaching sixth grade
in other words hook in Reverse create
resume Jumanji the vaguely African board
game that's ruined at least three
generations of kids lives we're all you
have to do is roll the dice then read a
slight variation on move your ass
the party that our move staying put
would be a blunder it's all just make a
run for it yeah eat just everyone get in
line and roll the dice and run guys
stampede and automatic start running
that's final impossible second cuz like
the hunter shows up Robin Williams runs
away from him like kind of loses him but
then like gets back in the house and
then like the game progresses but the
hunters still roaming though out there
the world everything's still out there
the Stampede shows up later yeah do they
just have to survive it yes sir my the
whole game just okay so it's all just
adding up and I will say that the new
one does actually add some structure up
to the Jumanji lure at least as far as
how the game works
fair enough but it's a different it set
it in a video game instead of a board
game since this is a different different
structure I wasn't the next Jumanji to
be like a freemium online game where
like coins yeah yeah to get a temporary
boost I think that um could you power
the game by like everybody just rolls
really [ __ ] fast like did she just
have everyone all the dice and then the
the pieces are zooming around possibly
possibly but then just everything hits
your house at once is it like yeah what
is the role if you're hmm if you can you
roll the dice anywhere could you like
set the game up because the pieces move
by themselves hop on a bullet train and
just start rolling mm-hmm I think the
animals would come into the bullet yeah
that's a bad situation all around
yeah that speed with Jumanji which I'd
watch come over think of this but yes
Jumanji on a train it's much better on a
train with ice and a film I'm gonna roll
those dice monkeys Oh finally jeez my
boy was sucked into a board game only to
emerge as a confused and hairy robbery
layers in this burg Harry
will you I hadn't seen this movie yet
and as I'm watching it I just keep
turning to you guys like this kids an
[ __ ] like I was just writing just
like notes after notes about like this
weird like annoying like rich kid and he
was punished with decades and you're
just cut in you were just kind of like
alright Joe like less notes and just
watch for like three more minutes you
won't be with them for long yeah really
go hard on this kid this is like a film
within a film within a film because it's
it's multiple layers of flashbacks down
it and alternate timelines and it's a
whole yeah that's a weird bizarre
universe the juban Traverse all right
keep it Jessa confused in Harry Robin
Williams her Harry her Robin Williams
now along with this traumatized playmate
Sarah and two super unlucky orphans
they'll do whatever it takes to finish
the game they started 26 years ago just
as soon as they finished talking about
having to finish the game they started
26 years ago on Harris for funding this
run really any time guys I know you're
upset but I kind of feel we should
finish the game
forget about lions and spiders and vines
because you're about to be hunted by
more serious stuff like unresolved
childhood issues last time I played this
game it ruined my life
bullying literal death she just died
beers about your own inadequacy that
manifest as mass shooters
and tons of PTSD and something screams
[Music]
and you hope to god - you're not desert
wow this is so much darker than I
remembered
pause there's like even more things that
we didn't include like there's just
randomly an exterminator who's like yeah
and and I chopped him up into little
pieces at least that's what I would do
really get it over and over again from
adults who have no respect for like
their childhood no I also have a
question about what's inside the Jumanji
game mmm is it like a cabin in the woods
situation where like every like Jumanji
thing is just queued up and like a
little and it goes they'll see the news
you'll find out about the Jumanji verse
okay alright terrorizing I'm in keep
going remembered my parents are dead to
watch romance balloon between Bonnie
Hunt and Williams just don't think too
hard about it because she's an adult and
he's still mentally a child real at the
happy ending where all the damage is
reversed but definitely don't think too
hard about that cuz 26 years of life on
earth got a race because some kids
finally beat the game you know I kind of
like my life but cool very happy for you
Bonnie
yeah that's strange because she they
everything flashes back to when Robin
Williams character first started the
game in like the late 50s or something
like that which they but and it seems
like they have one throwaway line that
seems like they're gonna forget what
happened because she's like I'm starting
to forget what it was like to be a adult
again that said then there's an epilogue
where they remember the kids and they
remember every single thing that
happened and not only that but where the
kid because it's like it's yeah you
remember a time also reset back to the
their childhood yes which meant that
Kirsten Dunst and her little brother
unborn but were then born with knowledge
of Robin Williams and Bonnie Hunt like
they were born and because then they
come to the party and they
clearly know each other what and yeah
and Bonnie knows everything that's going
to happen over the next 30 to 40 years
we have you'd think she could use to her
advantage and change the timeline game
the stock market so many things that's
the problem she was sold off I guess
that was a good thing oh yeah yes you
market that's some stock or something
yeah I don't know it's it's it's the
time travel paradox of resetting to the
original timeline but it's the same
thing as back to the futures like
obviously they wouldn't have that same
shitty house if George McFly was a
really good author but then Marty McFly
would just be walking into a stranger's
house um yeah so yeah you just have to
kind of go like whatever yeah I guess
we're back to future rules don't matter
will still matter nice keep going you
Bonnie so strategy felon or beyond yet
finally cracked the code for being a
good movie about a game base it on a
made-up game from a book filled with
characters you actually care about and
always cast Robin Williams man I miss
that guy starring Peter yeah major props
first infected himself this dollar store
Halloween decorations the reason that's
needed a reboot not a remake BB driver
Audrey to the Bad Lieutenant
Disney's Jungle Cruise and Andy Serkis
also movie star in arc and the NRA
you'll have to fill out these weirdo
take the Blues the game the movie nine
hobo Trobe we should bring that one back
yeah you're gonna freeze out there
[Laughter]
mister kindly hobo so and yeah they did
a great job of pulling all the old ones
but for me it is home alone probably has
the kind least hobos particularly home
alone to which great movie rules about
you know being kind and accepting of
others terrible real life lesson do not
approach strange first lady
and and go to their lofts above the
Metropolitan Opera House child alone
yeah that that you should follow the
spirit of the law and not the letter and
that in that and tell your parents yeah
before you so this town really go
speaking back to the future this town
goes full dark Biff timeline once that
shoot place closes I mean it the whole
town shudders yeah I mean that's got
away pretty heavily it if as if problems
hadn't been through enough is that just
him playing that game he not only had to
spend time in the jungle but also Hebrew
and his parents life and he ruined the
entire life of this town just because he
played a board game that he played to a
bullying yeah but it never happened so
but it all never never happened his life
never occurs very good for you Bonnie
good for you I'm mostly just excited
that the majority of the YouTube
comments will definitely not be about
the NRA joke
anyways let's say let's see some deleted
scenes in the movies getting a remake
now huh only a matter of time before
Jonah Hill does mrs. Doubtfire - it was
kind of odd that David Alan Grier
invents the sneaker all it wants on his
first try right then when his one
prototype is lost quits making shoes to
become a cop alright movie you're the
movie I do a that was those lawns I do
it took a while to get there I really
like the point and I also love the
phrase alright that's a great next week
maybe this week after a certain strange
film we're working on god yeah do we
have any alternate starring as we left
out nope that's it sweet
nothing nothing swell right and I feel
like we have because I feel like we have
to stand by tween wolf he looks like
Twiggy look I know he's not a wolf
he's a look just like we know he's
turning into a monkey but he looks like
team exactly when we had a meeting and
we decided it doesn't matter
here's all the monkey jokes in the world
but he looks like queen wolf when Joe
says he's not just not being hyperbolic
by the way these are the kind of things
that we have 5 to 10 minute long
discussions about is serious but we call
the kid in Jumanji tween wolf well the
well actually as we get out way the fact
that we didn't probably looks like teen
wolf and these this is our life
now I mean some people could save lives
fight fires you know do social work and
some people are heroes but some people
think you know it could have been Goku
could have been did whatever no he looks
like looks like Tina the real heroes are
behind this desk and watching at home
thank you guys so much for checking back
in for another week of honest trailer
commentaries gosh I love doing this show
and I love hanging out with you guys I'm
not sure if we're gonna be back for I
believe this is the last 2017 the
coverage perhaps we'll see if we can get
something done in time but man wouldn't
hold your breath and we will see you in
the new year for another bold new year
of honest trailers but we can probably
tease what the honest trailer will be
next week it will be the first of your
fan-voted honest trailers yeah do we
want to it's number five oh okay yeah I
know this one yeah it was one of the
weirdest movies we've ever done oh yeah
I'm sorry I was legitimately like if you
like complex mythology yeah if you like
I do is just the start yeah and if you
have questions about where babies come a
babies come from yeah yeah there you go
that's all we'll give you see you next
week or next year bye bye whatever
Mahalo
[Laughter]
you
[Music]